[Carcinoma of the esophagus: Fluoroscopic observations of advanced cases]
[Cinefluorography by Prof. Robert Janker, University of Bonn, Germany]
[Animated graphic of a man from the waist up]
[Camera zooms in and the internal organs are shown]
[Arrows point to the esophagus]
[Fluoroscopic images indicate a fluid flowing through the esophagus. The esophagus appears to narrow in places.]
[...]
[Animated graphic of the stomach and other internal organs that connect to the esophagus]
[Animated lines atop fluoroscopic image show a malignant growth in the esophagus]
[Fluid runs through the esophagus, showing how it is narrowed due to the growth]
[Arrows point to the narrowing and bulging at different spots on the esophagus]
[Esophagus and lungs are shown using fluoroscope]
[Animated arrows again indicate the existence and spread of a growth in or near the esophagus]
[Fluoroscopy shows the esophagus again, with fluid coursing through it]
[...]
[Fluoroscopic image of fluid flowing through esophagus.]
[Produced by Norman P. Schenker for the Medical Audio-Visual Institute of the Association of American Medical Colleges]
[Under a grant from National Cancer Institute, Public Health Service, US Department of Health, Education, and Welfare]